what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the Action Comics revenge
storyline coming out later today what I
wanted to do in this is basically one
over like the pre loot for it and this
is kind of interesting because DC's
doing this in a pretty intriguing way
for the most part DC's played it pretty
close with regards to the character
story arcs being confined within the
characters and so what you end up
getting instead and instead of these you
know massive crossovers are like these
you know two story crossovers so to
speak which is basically the Suicide
Squad crossing over with Superman and
that's one of the cool things here
because initially this picks up with lex
luthor now remember in the first story
that we covered because really we don't
we didn't really need the second story
it couldn't hurt but we didn't really
need the second story the first one
called the black vault that was the most
important and what this did is it
focused on the idea that that Amanda
Waller is leader of the Suicide Squad is
the head of the Suicide Squad had gained
information that there was basically a
black vault which is a portal to the
Phantom Zone the prison for Kryptonians
that was residing in Russia and the idea
was to basically break into this Russian
prison kill the black vault bring it
back to Belle Reve prison where the
Suicide Squad operates out of and then
see what they could do with it and of
course this eventually led to your death
of boomerang a Captain Boomerang which
of course he ended up coming back but
the idea here is that once the black
vault was secured by Amanda Waller they
basically discovered that General Zod
had come with it and so General Zod is
effectively Superman I mean he's just it
man by different means he's got the same
strength speed durability so on and so
forth
but he's also got a level of tactical
expertise that Superman doesn't have
because before general zod was
imprisoned in the Phantom Zone he was
the general of Krypton's armies and for
Amanda Waller
as the head of the Suicide Squad the
goal is to basically bolster the team's
ranks in a way to where it can be it is
virtually undefeatable team whenever it
is that is designed to carry out a
mission of some sort and so for her
acquiring General Zod was just as good
if not better than forcing Superman onto
the Suicide Squad the problem with this
is that cooperation from the various
members of the Suicide Squad is
guaranteed when the Amanda Waller has a
bomb planted inside of their brains with
General Zod they can't just plant a bomb
in his brain because he's virtually
indestructible if they were to plant a
bomb inside of his brain and then
detonated nothing would happen I mean it
probably scramble his brains a little
bit but he would certainly live and then
all hell would be paid and so be
cuz of that the idea was for Amanda
Waller to basically find a way to take a
General Zod
and make him her prisoner so what this
does is this picks up after that
original story and it has her meeting
with lex luthor's now this is cool
because remember Amanda Waller is just
as sinister and cruel as she is cunning
and intelligent and that's what makes
her so formidable is because she does
what needs to be done in order for her
to achieve her goal with Lex Luthor
remember in this new 52 or at least in
the DC rebirth iteration of his
character Lex Luthor is a good guy you
know he basically took up the mantle of
Superman after the original new 52
Superman died and the classic Superman
took his place now of course this led
into beef between the two of them and
you know whether or not Lex Luthor was
actually a good guy and so on and so
forth but we know he is but Lex Luthor
is basically just kind of offering or at
least he believes he's offering some
measure of distraction for Amanda Waller
what it's actually the other way around
and the reason why is because the
Suicide Squad is actually breaking into
Lex Luthor's building for the purpose of
accessing something now what that
something is we don't find out right off
the bat instead it's just kind of like
this quid pro quo going back and forth
between Amanda Waller and Lex Luthor
this little bit of bickering different
things like that but nothing super
significant the cool thing about this
though is that it does hit home at the
idea that because of Lex Luthor's
resources combined with his intelligence
he knows a lot of things that people
don't expect him to know the reason I
say that is because remember the Suicide
Squad is a black ops team they're
supposed to be in and out and no one was
supposed to know they were there for the
most part the Suicide Squad is known
around the world the issue is when the
Suicide Squad goes in and they commit an
act
what's the Danville isn't somebody else
and that's really the question that's
always left lingering at least at the
intention of Amanda Waller now of course
we end up finding out that this
particular object that the Suicide Squad
is looking for is kryptonite and the
reason why we know this is because of
the fact that once they break in Lex
Luthor immediately picks up on the fact
that they're there the other half of
this is this also ties into the origin
of the Xaro Superman and it's kind of a
cool thing remember back when the new 52
first started and Lex Luthor was a bad
guy he was trying to find ways to
basically create a clone of Superman and
he ended up creating all these different
iterations which went into the origin of
bizarro Superman bizarro Superman was
just this imperfect version of a
Superman that Lex Luthor had made but it
was the closest thing that he could
get to what this does is it gives us all
these different versions of Superman Lex
Luthor had made when he was going
through the cloning process to the gene
you know manipulation process now of
course for the most part the Suicide
Squad is able to hold their own to a
degree with Lex Luthor becoming aware of
the fact that they're there
he immediately races off and things
unfold exactly as we would expect to but
of course this leads to Lex Luthor
basically revealing to Amanda Waller
that he knows why they're there that
they're looking for kryptonite
now of course the reason why Amanda
Waller and her group are looking for
kryptonite is because in order for them
to make General Zod their guy in order
to basically force him into the Suicide
Squad they need a way to be able to
plant a bomb into his brain and that if
the detonates that it'll kill him and
green kryptonite will make that happen
the other half of this is that we also
get a little more information on the
character of harcourt I remember
hardware we talked about in the last
video I think it was and she's someone
who was basically introduced as part of
the Suicide Squad but we didn't know
anything about her all we knew is that
she was there to basically be the
liaison between the Suicide Squad and
the federal government but her
allegiance is who it was does she answer
to directly different things like that
we didn't really know any of that all we
knew is that Amanda Waller answered to
her and hardcourt answered to somebody
else now of course that's created a bit
of strain between Amanda Waller and
hardcore just because of the fact that
Waller doesn't like answering to anybody
in particular but what is it happening
here is they send out General Zod on his
first mission alongside the rest of the
Suicide Squad to basically track down
the annihilation brigade now remember
the annihilation brigade was the team
that the Suicide Squad first encountered
when they broke into the Russian prison
to steal the black vault and General Zod
in the first place and so because of
this what this tells us is that while
the Suicide Squad has tried to maintain
some level of clandestine nature
ultimately the world has become aware of
who they are and ultimately what ended
up happening here is that there was a
group called the people who have
basically created the Suicide Squad but
done it in a multitude of different
places and so it's really like this
international group with these different
hubs all over the place and so that's
one of the big huge drawbacks of Amanda
Waller that's one of the huge impacts
that we've talked about in previous
videos it was only a matter of time
before people learned about the Suicide
Squad and it was only a matter of time
before they tried to duplicate it or try
to copy it or something along those
lines now of course in response to this
we end up learning that harcourt is
basically a spy
for the people now she is a legitimate
agent but she's basically a double agent
she's operating you know as part of the
federal government feeding information
to the people organization and of course
we end up learning that the person who
is running this wench in prison was a
person by the name of director Karla and
ultimately she descends up you know
passionates information to recipie riyer
presumably and you know informing them
on General Zod and the various
weaknesses that he has and so on and so
forth but again what this does is it
creates a bit of tension for the squad
and the reason why is because of the
fact that remember despite the fact that
the various members of the Suicide Squad
have been shanghaied onto the team
ultimately they still have allegiances
to one another and they still have a
human side Harley Quinn is is just it
she's that crazy but at the same time
she's also still somewhat of a caring
human being and while they're in this
prison General Zod just kind of loses
his mind runs arrive attacks one of the
members of the annihilation Brigade who
can just let off these massive
explosions effectively detonates the guy
and obliterates the entirety of this
Russian prison the result of this is
that both Harley Quinn and Rick Flagg
are kind of struck by the fact that all
these lives have been lost as a result
of their actions of the Suicide Squad
now again this is a really anything new
it's really the first time that we're
kind of seeing like Harley Quinn and
Rick slide really get together but it is
kind of important in the sense that it
shows the human side of the characters
and that's one of the things that's
really easy to forget when it comes to
the Suicide Squad rather just villains
who were just kind of brought together
and forced to operate as a team and so
on and so forth now the other half of
this is hardcourt and Waller and that's
the cool thing about this remember
Amanda Waller is smart cunning ruthless
the whole nine yards and she immediately
picked up on what hardcourt was doing
the fact that hardcourt was a double
agent
now Amanda Waller did not initially know
who a hardcourt was working for but with
Amanda Waller's contacts with her
information coming out of the federal
government if she's tasked with a
superior then you better believe Amanda
Waller is going to do every ounce of
investigation she can find on that
particular person and with the character
of Harcourt she basically deduced that
Harcourt has no allegiances to anybody
in the government that nobody knows
anything about hardcourt she's just dare
one day and so she's effectively some
kind of a spy or something along those
lines
and so the result was that when Harcourt
had basically gone down into the science
area of the Bell Reef prison and killed
all those different science officers and
then interned send her message out to
director Carla data
waller put just enough bullets in there
for her to kill those members of the
science officers and then have no
bullets left and so this of course
allows for hardcore to be overpowered or
at least to be taken out by Captain
Boomerang now the other half of this is
again Harley Quinn and ricflack the two
of them basically share romantic
interests with one another and that's
one of the cool things here is because
again it's very much the human side of
the Suicide Squad who are just trying to
find some measure of happiness in a life
that's otherwise devoid of any real
happiness whatsoever and so of course
this also shows us the general zod is
pre ruthless in the sense that his
motivation is to re-access the black
vault find a way to retrieve people who
were inside and then bring them out into
the world now the way this is done is
really really cool because on this
surface it seems like he just wants to
free these various members of Krypton's
armies and conquer the world but what
we're actually going to find out in
another story later on is that there's a
far deeper motivation to this there's
something a lot more personal that he's
trying to get out of there so it's
really cool but what this does is it
leads to him basically
incinerating the bomb inside of his own
head literally using his heat vision
reflecting it off a mirror and
destroying the bomb in his head so again
it's really kind of cool because it
shows us the lengths that he's willing
to go to in order to achieve his goal
now of course with him basically
incinerated the bomb in his own head why
can't help but scream when you're
shooting lasers into your skull so of
course the rest of the Suicide Squad
here's the whole thing along with Amanda
Waller and they all basically respond
now the reason for this is because
you're number this is General Zod and
General Zod is fairly new to the Suicide
Squad to say nothing of the fact that
when they first encountered him he
basically almost defeated the entirety
of the squad himself and then some and
so of course if he's gone awry if he's
lost his mind and they attempt to
detonate this bomb the hope is that
it'll kill him only for them to find out
that he removed the bomb from his own
head and so what it means now is there's
no conventional means for them to stop
General Zod they are effectively
helpless at his whim now the Suicide
Squad jumps in you know they all arrived
just in time in order to be able to you
know try to stop Zod but that's really
about it the best they can hope to do
it's keyed amid keep them at bay and the
reason for this is because what he
begins doing is basically releasing all
these phantoms own race basically these
spirits of people who have been
imprisoned in the Phantom Zone and allow
them to just kind of
amok and sort of hacking things now of
course this coincides with the arrival
of a cyborg superman hank henshaw and
the Eradicator now remember in the
events leading up to Action Comics
revenge what this did is it gave us this
notion that somebody had been going
around and somebody had been bringing
together the various enemies of Superman
of course read of having blank one of
the most notable enemies who has just an
insane amount of telepathy and
telekinesis but we don't know anything
about him Mongol who's basically this
longtime enemy of Superman who's tried
to defeat him on a multitude of
occasions as well as metallo a guy who's
basically you know uses a kryptonite
heart one of Superman's most notable
enemies as well but of course this is
revealed to be hank henshaw himself who
is bringing them around now if you're
new here the long and short of this and
the only thing you really need to worry
about is it's cyborg Superman it's
probably Superman's most formidable
enemy probably his most dangerous enemy
just because of the fact that so long as
his or his uh you know computer
components are intact cyborg superman
cannot truly die he can always be
reassembled and so again that's one of
the things that makes them so so
dangerous here now of course General Zod
does not see them as legitimate he
doesn't see them as guys that are like
hey look you guys can be my allies you
guys can be on my side
General Zod is a pure Kryptonian he
believes that only pure Kryptonians have
the right to lead the Kryptonian army
and so again really looks at decide
where Superman he's like you're not a
real Kryptonian you're like a machine
hybrid when he looks at the Eradicator
the Eradicator is artificially created
and possessed by the souls of countless
Kryptonians when it comes to General Zod
himself he is a genuine Kryptonian and
that's one of the reasons why is on it
always harbored this sort of hatred
towards Superman himself because
Superman's family were ones that
basically led to General Zod being in
prison in the first place General Zod
popping up here is for the purpose of
just bringing Krypton back and that's
one of the reasons why his character is
so cool because it's not that
unreasonable General Zod is not like a
Nazi right he's not like all ran you
know only purebloods only the pure race
not at all for him Krypton's been
destroyed his allegiance is to Krypton
the Kryptonians restoring his planet
back to its rightful place if he can't
bring Krypton back in the traditional
sense that he can very well inhabit the
earth with Kryptonians but again that's
the surface explanation his intention
the whole reason why he wants to
get back into the black vault is a lot
more personal with this black vault
serving as a source of all these rates
as well as general zod feeding on its
power to a degree other attempt to
basically take out the black vault
aren't necessarily the most successful
and so what rick flagg ends up doing
it's traveling directly into the heart
of the black vault itself and then
effectively destroying it with grenades
and so on and so forth now again the
black vault is basically a portal to the
Phantom Zone but it's basically
destroying the portal doorway that's
really all it is all the purpose of the
black vault serves and so because of
this rick flagg is presumed to have been
killed now we don't know his final fate
that final fate is not given to us he's
just inside the Phantom Zone now most
likely he's just a April poriyal spirit
or something along those lines but
remember he had those grenades in his
hand when they went off or at least
that's what we saw and so the
presumption is that he's effectively
killed now again the reason why I say
this is so personal for General Zod is
because of the fact that with the black
vote gone with the portal to the Phantom
Zone gone he effectively just gives up
and all he says is they're gone he does
really kind of Falls and says that's it
they're gone I give up but the cool
thing about this is that while he does
leave with cyborg superman any
Eradicator because they promised him a
way to gain access to the Phantom Zone
one of the things that General Zod tells
Amanda Waller is that she has no earthly
clue how close she was to wiping out the
whole of humanity and that's really one
of the things that the story hits it's
you know really hits in the heart when
it comes to Waller herself Waller
despite how her intelligence her cunning
at the end of the day she's largely
blinded by her own arrogance and her own
ambition she wants to win that's what it
is and she'll do whatever it takes to
win but it's not really until after the
circumstances are over after she's hid a
moment of panic that she begins to
realize oh my god everything could have
gone awry now these feelings of
uncertainty these feelings of a lack of
confidence are masked by Amanda Waller's
personality she never reveals to the
suicide squad that she's not sure that
what she's doing is the right thing and
that's why this is so cool is because it
gives us this other side of Amanda
Waller that we never really see Amanda
Waller starved she's worthless she's
cunning she's cruel but on the inside
she questions every step she makes she
questions every decision she makes is
she doing the right thing what happens
if the Suicide Squad goes left instead
of right if they go left the earth is
safe if they go right the entire Earth
is destroyed all that stuff
all of humanity walks on a knife's edge
and at any point it can all come
crashing down because of a stupid
decision that Amanda Waller made and so
again that's a crazy thing because now
the question the suicide squad has is if
Rick Flagg is dead and Rick Flagg is the
field commander and he's the only one
who is intelligent and reasonable then
who in God's name is going to lead the
suicide squad now what would that be
said guys if you are new here to come
and explain make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the Rob
port you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like yeah this goes
directly into Action Comics revenge just
because this focuses on why it is that
General Zod joins the revenge squad in
the first place so again I want to throw
this in there I'm going to throw this
into the Superman playlist as well just
so people have an idea of where General
Zod came from walls above the first
Suicide Squad video in there too anyway
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]